breaking news on the covid 19 vaccine
being developed by scientists at oxford
university um our science correspondent
thomas more
joining us now it looks so it's pretty
effective thomas good morning
yes indeed it uh it shows that if you
give the
vaccine in a particular way that you can
get 90 percent
uh effectiveness uh across the board uh
and that is hugely exciting and now what
they're saying is that you what you need
to do is to give a half strength
first dose and then a full strength
second dose
so that leads to this 90 percent figure
now what they're saying is that by
halving that first dose not only do you
make vaccine more effective there's more
of it to go round
which of course is going to be great
news when everybody is clamoring
for a vaccine uh to bring this pandemic
to an end
they found that this is the first time
this has been shown judging from the
the reduction in the number of
asymptomatic individuals that's people
who don't develop
symptoms after being infected with the
virus that
this vaccine may actually reduce virus
transmission and that's important
because
up to now that this has been this
question of whether vaccines just reduce
disease
or reduce infection rates and this
vaccine does seem to be
stopping the virus spreading now if we
want to get the economy back on its feet
that is what will be needed in terms of
side effects they're reporting that
there were no
hospitalized individuals following
vaccination and no severe infections
so as far as they can tell this vaccine
is safe
they say that this is astrazeneca saying
that
they have already begun large-scale
manufacturing
in 10 countries so this can be rolled
out as quickly as possible